[Music]
what we know is that Saddam has this
material you don't know that I mean he
just keeps releasing the light just
because you're the Prime Minister it
doesn't mean you get to make up your own
facts someone in this building has
betrayed their country
if you are found to have withheld
information you will be charged with a
breach of the Official Secrets doesn't
go how did you think like this because
remember all you this friend be careful
this is real you can go to jokes for
having in your possession you're a spy
you work for the British government
no I work for the British people I do
not collect information so that the
government can lie to the British people
intelligence may be being manipulated to
take this country to all this stop
taking Tony Blair at face value
you had nothing to gain and everything
to lose this could result in a prisoner
sentence do you want to risk it all
[Applause]
everywhere every country biggest
demonstration in human history we do not
go published we would be conceding that
no one had ever told the people when
their government is lying
[Music]
we did
I was extraordinary the war is illegal
the public is entitled to know why my
motive was to stop a war and save lives
I have to tell the truth
[Music]
you